I remember I met somebody that was on uh
you know what I'm talking about c-u-m-t
compound yeah you I think we met way
back in the day was it serious it's
serious yeah did you have no did you
have children no hair dude yeah dude
like oh my God seven years ago we did a
serious raw dog podcast and it's like
none of I mean like you were doing
better but not like this and I was
nowhere like we were just like God you
were like a guy working clubs and I was
a guy working like Thursdays and Sundays
oh my god dude I have looked up because
you didn't know that was me no you
didn't know the bald guy you made it
serious six years ago it was me
and I've been looking for him
that's not even a funny dude I know
you're not I can see it in your eyes and
I'm like I swear to God this dude was
from Compton
wow yeah dude we met so long ago and
that was a fun that was a fun podcast
that we didn't know each other at all we
were just kind of shooting the [__] so
was it
I don't know it was like uh or that guy
Aaron no dude it was like it was like
the guy like like such a low level
serious show it was like the producers
son or something yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was hilarious and it wasn't even like a
studio it was like in an office they put
four mics in remember yeah I was like
you know what the [__] you know I
remember yeah somebody yelled the n-word
right when I walked in there sorry about
that
I was like all right I'll stay yeah
sorry Sherrod made me really mad
how long was Sherrod small
the only black dude in that Circle that
rotation dude Opie had charad back to
back that's cool bro yeah that's a cool
cat man R.I.P yeah
let's spread let's start that Sharon's
been dead for years I miss him yeah good
guy though good guy what are you gonna
do yeah and so you guys don't do that
anymore you guys still no she stopped we
stopped the show like uh
last year I would dude I was [__]
because you love bro I remember you
telling me how freaking good it was it
was fun dude it was a fun it was a fun I
remember that now yeah we just we had
just started and the show was I looked
at the lettering it had semen coming off
like yeah it was pure come uh but that's
the show you do when you're like you
know in your mid-20s with your boys and
it was like yeah when you got extra calm
yeah when you got come to spare
and now I'm I need every I need I need
to you know I'm drinking extra fluids
when I know I'm Gonna Make Love I want
to make sure I'm fully I'm getting an IV
straight to my balls just to make sure
you coming there
but yeah dude the show was [__] fun
for a while and then you know I was like
damn am I gonna be the calm Town guy
when I'm 40. oh you know it's like you
can't when you're when the brand yeah
yeah
and if most people in my life were like
uh yeah you will be come on dude stop
having stop getting greedy you fight you
found the gimmick stick with it you'll
have to make [__] dick you know being
gay with your friends jokes until you
die which I still do something right
none of that will ever end yeah it
shouldn't yeah no no no but you know so
then it was just like uh
you know I was like an evolution kind of
yeah I just want to do my own thing
because it's like I like you know
because you do your own show it's nice
to just be the only person who has to
schedule anything you just do it on your
own time oh yeah [__] you know yeah I
mean I did another show too for a while
I did King in the sting and it was fun
but I started to miss I didn't have
enough energy really to focus on like
what my own world was yeah yeah and what
made me feel comfortable and the
scheduling it becomes a lot people think
we're only working a couple hours a week
it's a lot it's there's a lot more to it
that you don't see exactly not
complaining but that's what it is yeah
and that was basically it where I was
like I also just really wanted to focus
on stand up and I had this I had the
special just come out and I was like you
know I thought I was gonna just like
kind of take a little break special was
out retool do all this [__] and then I
stopped doing come town and then my [__]
blew up and I was like wait I can't the
break is never happening yeah I've just
been on the road for two years since
like I still I have to take like after
that's why I'm filming this special it's
a little early but I was like I need the
summer off because I'm gonna [__] die
like yeah as long you will die so uh so
yeah
um and I just kind of like really went
crazy on stand up and then just after a
while I was like I guess I should just
do a podcast I'm good at it so I just
started stabby's World
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one